Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
This is Custard.
Today, we have two amazing teams
who have very kindly or badly broken some
Kubernetes clusters for the other team to fix.
Before we introduce our first team, we are
going to say hello and thank you to
our sponsors.
So Teleport have been sponsoring Clustered since almost
the very beginning, and we've been using Teleport
since the very first episode.
Teleport is an amazing tool, allows us to
commoditize access
to each of these bare metal clusters.
The fan grained RBAC controls and a pairing
ability, which you will see us using on
every single episode of Clustered. So thank you
Teleport.
Also, thank you to Equinix Metal. They've been
providing the hardware again, since the very first
episode. These bare metal machines are awesome. They
have tons of cores, tons of memory,
tons of fun to be had for people
that wish to break and fix clusters.
So thank you, Equinix. It's always a pleasure.
All right. Let's introduce our first team. I'm
gonna pop over to here and we're gonna
say hello to team ambassador labs.
Hello all. How are you?
Very good. Thanks, Dave. Very good. Awesome. I
love to I do this every time and
I haven't found a way better to do
it. Like, I say hello to a group
of people and then they all just like,
oh, which one who's gonna speak? Like
However, I'm really excited to to have you
all here. And why don't we start at
the top right, work our way around clockwise,
and each of you to say hello and
introduce yourself, please.
Hello, everybody.
My name is Alex. I'm a software developer
at Ambassador Labs, and I'm based out of
Montreal.
Cool.
Hi, everyone. My name is.
I work as a developer advocate at Ambassador
Labs, and I'm based in Lagos, Nigeria.
Hey, everyone. Daniel Bryan here, head of DevRel
Ambassador Labs. Previous life as a Java developer,
and then moving across the ops. So I'm
hoping my Linux knowledge comes flooding back today.
Right?
It will.
It's alright. I'm sure nobody ever attacks the
Linux machine. Right? They just do a nice
easy breaks on the Kubernetes cluster.
That's what I'm saying. Alright.
Well, you are up against a returning team,
team fair winds. We will see them in
around forty five minutes time.
But let's get started with our cluster for
today. So we are gonna pop open my
screen share.
I've already connected to the control plane node.
So if you could each please join the
session and just type echo hello or anything
to let me know that you are there.
And then I will wish you best of
luck and you can kick this off.
All right. We got a hello,
two hellos.
Let's see if we can get there we
go. That's there's London.
Awesome.
Off the flying star. That's that's the hard
bit done. So
I'll let you just take it from here.
Set up your cube config, check for a
control plane and best of luck.
Awesome stuff. Shall I drive folks, first off?
Then you can shout out stuff.
Yes. Please go ahead. Cool. How half the
Fairwinds folks been we love Fairwinds. Have they
been nice to us? Right?
Let's see. We'll find out soon.
Notes.
Oh.
Oh, we have start. For a control plane.
Well, supposedly. I know they've done some tricks
in the past. I do get notes. I
guess I get pods.
It's looking pretty good. Right?
Yeah. It looks like everything is running as
well. Yeah. Restart on the controller manager.
Interesting. Yeah. Conveniently, like, an an a day
ago, right, when you would have been playing
around with stuff?
Let's Okay.
David, can we see if v one is
running,
please?
It's then crash look back off. So if
you take that for less, I've I've screwed
up as well for the audience, but the
cluster pod is is a broken pod. Ah,
thanks. That was great. Wishful thinking, You know?
Yeah. Yes. Worth a try. Right? Shall we
Yeah.
Describe on that one?
Yeah. So that's where the problem is. Sure.
Get the events.
Yeah. It seems every other one is running
aside from that.
So we got waiting, crash loop, back off,
terminated,
oom killed.
Java developer. I know that all too well.
Spinning up Spring. I love Spring, of course,
but often gets him killed. Look
at the limits on this pod. He has
10 megabytes.
Well spotted, Alex. Well spotted.
Yeah.
Back off, reset. Liveness probe failed health
as well.
What's the recommendation, everyone? What do you think?
Let's try and bump up the memory limit.
Yep. What's the command on that one? That's
feel free to type if want it as
well.
I
don't recall by hand. I'd probably do a
kubectl edit. Yeah.
Sounds good. Right? Should do that.
Yeah. Edit deployment. I think that's your best
bet here.
So what you're in prod. Right?
Yeah.
The deployment then.
What's it called? Cluster. Right? It's just called
cluster dash. Right? Yeah.
And I will show this through here.
It's a weird bug. There we go.
Oh, yes. Can you demonstrate to my screen?
Oh, gotcha.
Got the
checks there. There's the limits. Right? So I
added them?
Yeah. What what are we going for, do
you reckon?
I think we should remove
everything.
Exactly. Sledgehammer approach.
We
don't need limits. Come on.
Yeah.
And yeah. Happy with that?
Yep.
That's not good.
There you go.
Resources
column.
Supposedly running there. Right?
It is. It does appear
to be running.
Do I love that Rust application instantly fast
fire instantly fires out. Right?
Would you like me to test it? Yes,
please. There it is, please. Alright. That would
be we're we're clearly expecting it tonight. It's
gonna go in flames. Right? The Fairwinds people
are far too devious.
So
normally
oh, there's my LinkedIn. Normally,
there is a node port service in 30,000.
But can you just double check that for
me and run out a get service?
Run out what side, dude?
I'm sorry. Get services. I just wanted to
make sure that Yeah.
So I would have expected that to work.
I will check one more thing just in
case it's my setup
because I am also prone to a lot
of errors.
I'll get the public IP address. Oh, it's
not there.
Oh, yeah.
Too many clusters.
So just in case.
They left you a message. Gotcha. It says
gotcha. I
was just gonna do a carol, right, on
the
Oh, yeah. We could've just done a carol
look was, but I'm jumping around looking at
it here. So No worries. And that's why
I was just like, just talking. I lost
connection.
No. It's back. Here we go. Yep.
Yeah.
I was gonna do a call local host.
Freaking Fairwinds
Insight can help you with your
done team. Bet you save your resources. Actually,
on that note, have we got we have
got some hints if we need them. Right?
Thank you, Fairwinds folks. I believe it's hints
there if we we need them.
Cool. Well, what are you thinking now?
Should we check for network policies? Anything like
that?
Yeah. Because, obviously, something is
answering our request,
but not the application that we're expecting. So
maybe you look at the the ingress configuration
or the So we couldn't find node port,
Alex, aren't we? So no ingress.
Although there is m s s s ingress
deployed to the cluster. Just throwing that out
there.
Emissary ingress is a nice ingress. Who works
on that?
We love emissary ingress. Right?
Yeah. And I I one of the first
things I did when I saw emissary ingress
there is I was like, what what listeners
are set up? What mapping is set up
in my cluster and of course didn't find
any. And then I figured out you're using
no port to expose these things. Yeah. I've
been improving the setup over the last month,
and I just brought in ingress. So, yeah,
I will be exposing over
some shiny domain Know where we are, David.
I can help with those listeners host some
mappings. Emitter ingress is one of the if
not the best ingress out there. Right?
Cool. So we've got yeah. So it doesn't
look like emissary is being used in terms
of mappings
or even probably it's worth just checking listeners
because that would be very cruel to leave
it. Yeah. Nothing I suppose I should do.
So looks like it's not a
panemissary ingress thing.
No.
But, I mean, you're having an application that
looks like my application.
I mean, what should we be checking next?
Yeah. The image, I think, is a good
good idea. Right? Yeah. Definitely. Checking the image.
So
if we just do we've already done the
describe, actually, on the
on the deploy. Right?
What's the line? On the pod, not on
the deployment.
Yeah. If I just keep
what do think I should do on the
pod
or
on the deployment?
Well, we did it on the pod initially.
We can take a look at the deployment
as well.
Because it says, right, image g hcr.i
o Rawkode clustered v one.
So the image looks legit. Right? That's what
we expected when we were messing up with
our cluster. Mhmm.
Yeah.
Screw to it. I like it when things
look legit.
Yeah. You know there's something we could try
bumping it to v two. Right? Because that
the ultimate goal here is to try and
get to v two. If you see what
happens there, I reckon the Fairwinds team might
have left us a nice little surprise there
as well. Well, that is the that is
the voice of a experienced cluster or as
well, and you've not been on before. Yeah.
Let's give it a try. Right? Yeah. That's
a good idea.
Edit. Deploy.
Plastic.
Well,
It is running. It's restarted. If I just
do
a local host again, see what we've got
there.
Uh-huh. It's gonna be alright. Boiled. Yeah.
So do we
do we think potentially
someone's
messed around with the registries?
Actually pulling them like a Are you can
you describe the I would doubt it. Walking
into I heard it's
always full policy
on the deployment. So
I would imagine that we are getting the
image from the registry, and it's not preloaded
on the machine.
Oh, yeah. Image full policy always. Yeah. I'm
with you, Alex.
If you describe the part as the image
the same?
You
get.
Kubectl.
My pod.
Pulling image?
Yeah. But it it does appear to be
pushed down correctly.
So Yeah. It looks like it's bit That's
fun.
What if we do
big on g
h c r?
See if that's
Do you know the IP address of that
off the top of your head?
I do not, but I was thinking if
it was, like, loop back or something, it'd
be crazy, like
That looks pretty legit, actually. But I'm just
thinking, where's that going to?
Because that that would be the
just thinking, like, to your point logically here,
Alex, like, is something intercepting
that port
before it's even getting here? Or
is it the image? What do you think
of the junk? Like, I wonder if I'm
we might be getting led astray. Right?
I mean, I I know we're actually talking
about, like, network policy. Right? And then you
mentioned there was an existing note, so there's
no way to track that. Because ideally,
that could be the problem. Maybe they set
some
commands that prevents us from accessing it directly.
So Like,
for the people watching then, right,
if you had a NodePort service,
can you follow that thread? Like,
what endpoints does it have? Does the pod
IPs match up? Like, you you could kind
of work that out. Right?
Yeah. Interesting.
What's the perk folks' thoughts on that? So
the Let's look at the the
service node port
and probably the endpoints
being served by this for this service.
Do you wanna drive, Alex? My
Internet is a bit flaky, so I think
I'll I'll
You're shout shout what to type in that
case then.
Let's
start by listing all services.
Yep. I
like your thinking.
So we have
a note for on the clustered service.
Yep.
Mhmm. Let's look at the kubectl
get endpoints
for this clustered service.
You've got a cuddle
get endpoints?
Yep. K.
We can just run that as is if
you wish.
And now you've got 8080? Yeah. Well, you've
got a port you've got an IP address.
You may wanna Then we can, yeah, get
pods
dash
o wide to get the
pod IPs.
Yep.
You have a match. It does match. So
that rules out the hypothesis.
Nice thought, did it. Nice thought.
It's a cool effect, this.
Image compose it always.
Image name appears to be correct down the
stack,
but the image Is it car port? It's
all that, I wonder. Sidecar container, sorry.
Didn't see anything, did we? No. It it
I I don't believe so.
It says one of one ready, so one
container.
Couldn't I couldn't do anything clever with the
in it containers or I know the Fairwinds
folks have used all the Kubernetes real estate
in the past.
So let's assume
that the request is set in the correct
pod, but somehow the Fairwinds team have put
something in place that well, Kubernetes believes this
is the correct image, that they're actually doing
sneaky sneaky stuff.
So what's responsible
for pulling the image to the machine?
The Docker daemon
or
Yep. Docker container d c r I and
the kubelet has some involvement. So maybe start
I may have to start poking at those,
I think.
How was your Didi Dong, Alex, what's your
experience like with the
with the cryo stuff?
The the Fairbench team are also reminding us
we have hints. It's alright to use the
hints. Thank Kevin's team. Appreciate it. Sweet sweet
Yeah. Cat them with that. Good idea. So
we got some chat from the comments
saying mutating webhook.
Now, it doesn't feel like mutating webhooks because
what we're seeing in the state
and the edit pod
would be different. Right? If they had mutated
the
the payload. Yeah. Yeah. So it's a good
you know, they're they're sort of Oh, people
do love mutating webhooks on clusters. I do
gotta say.
And
I got one, I think.
It doesn't have to take a look at
Xeno, but I think you probably fixed the
error rate.
Oh, look at that.
Some ASCII art. What's
that say? Fairwinds versus
ambassador's ass.
I don't know if you get my Yeah.
Unfortunately.
Okay. Quite mean. Ambassador, I think. Right? I'm
gonna
Let's out. There we go. Oh, nice. Nice.
That
is nice. That is nice. I like that.
Very cool, actually.
Yeah. Kudos for that one. I mean, not
a hint. Just I mean, if we're sticking
to the rules, I'm just saying.
To be fair, think your rules do say
zero one is the first hint, David. Little
bit like Built
in system namespaces can hide all sorts of
junk.
Built in. So, like, static static pods.
Yeah. Like, those namespaces that come directly with
Kubernetes.
Yeah. I wonder if we do l s
e t c Kubernetes
manifests.
We're gonna see
who we expect. Right? API server controller, keep
the case of that VIP. But I wonder
if each of them have got
do you think I'm gonna rabbit hole here?
I'm wondering if each of them have got
what we expect. We could cap them. I'm
also could dim them and have a look.
Or is there an easier way to go
in system namespace? It's gonna have all sorts
of I mean, you could trust the timestamp.
Running in the cube system names.
Sorry.
Sorry. Sorry. Folks, what was that? Yep.
I think you mentioned something around system.
Right?
So, like, you still get namespaces and then
find try to, like, get things in that
namespaces, see what exists inside of it. Because
it it seems like they hit something inside
the that particular namespace, if I'm not mistaken.
I think you're right, Eddie. Yeah. Just look
to David's point. That's a suspicious March 2,
yeah, yesterday on coop controller manager. Right?
Yeah. Exactly. That's a good hint, I think,
there.
We just go with him. Right?
Interesting.
So
that one's definitely for folks watching, should contain
some YAML.
That says did you put the path in
or just the fail in him? Oh, that's
cheers, dude. Yeah. I've
you're right. I just my my badge will
be oh, yeah. Just do
ahead of myself. Right?
Fox boys. Great work.
That's more like it. Right?
Yeah. That that's what you expect.
Shall we actually, I'm trying think what's the
what's best to do here? It go go
to the top? I mean, when I open
a fail and my customer doesn't start in
lane one, I would maybe look at what
it was around.
You what? So David? When I opened a
file of them and my cursor is 200
lines down, I would probably check there first
rather than go to the top of the
file. Hundred?
That's
that's a good question. You're right at the
end of the I was it's the driving
mentality. I'm so in in the terminal.
Yeah. Was it right at the end? That
is Oh, it was. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. I
think they might have thought that.
Can
I use control f and b on this
one?
B. There we go.
Chat if anything looks
suspicious, folks.
Yep.
Okay.
That part, is that is that supposed to
be healthy?
I'm not sure.
Yeah. A lot of them are healthy. There's
a good point, though. Some of them are
health some of them are healthy. Right? So,
yeah, you you're right. Oh, okay. There's little
bit of suspicion, but I think I know
the XCD ones are health, for example, versus
healthy. Yeah. If you I think you'll find
if it comes from a Google developer, they've
got a concept of z pages, then you'll
see health z. Oh, okay. Okay. Actually, David,
I wondered where that rule came from. Yeah.
It looks alright. Yeah? It does. It does.
Yeah.
Any
thoughts, team? Any thoughts? Because it does it
looks pretty legit. Right?
Yeah. It's good.
Is it It does look good, Harry.
Yeah. Sorry, Alex.
Well, suppose it is. It's probably an ad,
man. Now it does look good to me.
There
there was one thing that covers you, but
I I don't wanna send you down any
rabbit holes. So
Oh.
But time to speak like, something Didion mentioned,
you're about looking at namespaces, Didion. Right? We
try that. Yeah. Let's run the system.
Namespaces.
So, like, what we're thinking? Kube CTL?
Gets namespaces.
So just yeah. So
maybe, like, Kube CTL gets all and then
specify the Kube system namespace
to see
what's inside of it.
How do you do that again, do you
know? Keep you still get all dash n
for that? Yeah. Yes. Yes. And then keep
system.
Think. Oh, not that much.
We got a bunch of Cilium, CoreDNS.
There
is something wrong with
KubeDNS.
Seems like there's been multiple replica set of
could they have been trying
to deploy a new version with a new
configuration of core DNS that would have forced
Rawkode replicas?
Yeah. That would concern me too, definitely.
Interesting, Alex. Yeah. Interesting. Yeah.
DNS, right, could be pointing
in the wrong direction.
How best to it's funny how we're trying
it off camera. Was like, one thing I
don't wanna do is call DNS. I'm really
not very good at call DNS. Right? I
thought the cluster the Fairwinds team must have
been like, yep. We're just loving that.
So there's a few different train of thoughts
right now. Okay? You got the DNS, you
got the hint which alluded to stuff in
hiding inside of a cube system or system
based namespace.
But the effect that you're currently dealing with
is the fact that the image isn't the
image that we want it to be. Yeah.
So I think you need to just pick
one of those and let's
let's focus on it. Hnt o one
probably should be the thing we focus on.
Ever fixing things in order. However, you could
just go straight for the image.
So
So you're thinking the namespace stuff, David? I
mean, that would be the journey that Fairwinds
want you to go down just based on
the order of the hints.
But, you know Yeah. The mission is just
to get v two running. So it's entirely
up to you.
What are thinking, team?
Yeah. I think we'll go ahead to
let's just start somewhere because we don't know
for sure where the error is.
Yeah. Let's look at that head again. Yeah.
Let's let's remind ourselves with that headset.
It was
one. It was one. Yeah.
Yep. Sorry.
Built in system namespaces can hide all sorts
of junk.
of junk. Yeah. So, I mean, it's possible
that it's not exactly the cube system. I
think when I saw system,
I assumed it was cube system. So it
could be any other v built in namespaces.
Yeah. I think you're right. I would I
would take a look at those namespaces that
we always ignore
and see what's running.
I think that's a good idea.
So what are we thinking, Max?
We look at what gives CDL get an
s?
Yes. Let's check each other one of them.
I think we we could try public.
I just want to kubectl
get all thinking? Get all. Yes. And then
dash namespace.
Dash n, then new namespace.
Interesting.
Postgres there? Kube public.
Because you said the Postgres be running in
default. Right? That is well, yeah, that's what
I wanted.
Yeah. Should we continue down this should we
have a quick look at node lease?
Just see what's Yeah.
I think we should just check that out.
Even though node leases usually used to keep
the notes. No resources.
Right there.
We've already done system. Right?
Yeah.
Is it worth just checking?
I mean, it'd evil. We mean even to,
like, put something in emissary. Right?
I think that looks pretty legit. Right? That's
Yeah. This looks legit.
I wonder what the image in that Postgres
pod might be.
Yeah. It's a good good thing you're nice.
Yeah. Let me just
matches what we would expect to find. Superhackerimage.one.
Yeah. I like that. I you're I like
yeah. So and this is yeah. Right? Low
balancer. Yeah.
So
kubectl.
Yeah. All
was it it was
what's the name of the
The cube dash public was the one that
was suspicious. Yeah. There was cube dash public.
Yes. Yeah.
Cube public. So can you describe on the
deployment, do you think?
It doesn't look like a deployment.
Yeah. I think it's deployed.
Default set. Okay. So that's all set. Oh,
yeah. Oh, yeah. Cool. So Yeah. Yep. Keep
CTL.
And it's only twenty five hours old. That's
suspicious timing.
Indeed. Should
we just what's the idea? Describe on the
portal?
I think describe should give us more context.
Yeah.
Oops.
Alright. We're halfway through.
Image Postgres 13 Alpine.
Docker.
Liveness.
Exact p g ready.
So I'll give you some information about how
my setup works because I think it's pertinent
right now. So the postgres at the default
namespace is not a stateful set. At least
I I don't think it is.
Or it may be, but it doesn't use
any persistent volumes and the data is all
Oh, okay. Is all loaded through in in
a container.
So
it could be that they have provided their
own postgres with different data to inject onto
the page.
Interesting. Let's In which case, we should be
able to configure which Postgres is being used
by the application.
I'm assuming there's a configuration
environment variable
or something.
There is a Postgres running in the default
namespace. Right?
Yep. I think that's the one, if I'm
mistaken.
Yeah. It's also 25 years old.
Interesting.
Yes.
Yeah. Interesting. So
I'm wondering,
you in your
config there, Dave, for that
for that deploy I think you use deployment
to
inject some config for the Postgres?
It may very well be entirely hard coded
to just
Postgres.
So if you run get services, I'd be
curious to see what we see there.
Standard cluster IP.
Yeah. And it's two days old, whereas the
other one was twenty something hours.
Yeah.
We just do
we we don't describe that one. I mean,
if we do describe on
right. Just keep
detail.
Describe on the service.
Think
scrolling up through. Hopefully, folks can see this.
Oops.
Yeah. So my application is hard coded to
speak to a service called Postgres
and the same namespace.
So
if we cannot change the endpoint
for that thing That's if it's my application
running.
Yeah.
Which I I'm not convinced of.
But maybe there's something to do with core
DNS?
Yeah. We've seen those replica sets. Alex, you
were suspicious about them. Right? Yeah.
They could be forwarded onto something else. Good
catch. Onto another namespace. Right?
Yeah. That that makes a lot of sense.
How would we go back yeah. My core
DNS knowledge is somewhat limited.
How do we go back Yeah. Finding that
one out? Everybody says because why would you
why would you need to configure core DNS?
It just works. Right? Yeah. Exactly. Like, I
mean, it's always DNS, right, as the as
the joke goes, but why do we need
to configure it?
Let's maybe describe the core DNS pods and
figure out if there's a config map or
kind of configuration that's There is. There's a
config map in KubeSystem called core DNS.
Or, yeah. Maybe cube DNS. I can't remember.
But if you've listed config maps in cube
system, you will see what you're looking for.
In
cube system.
Yeah. CoreDNS is one.
Does it just get config map
or describe what is it? It was it
KubeS? I thought it was cubes public. Was
it cubesystem?
Was it not cubes public? We
so Okay. Well, cubes public is where the
rogue postgres is, but the core DNS configures
in cubesystem. And you can just system. Alright.
Add dash o yaml to that if you
wanna look at it. Yes, Oh, sure.
I'll check lame duck five seconds. That's interesting.
It's a rewrite.
It's tough.
Interesting.
So what do we think it
I think we should Should be like not
rewrite this. This
should public.
Oops. Just
to edit. Edit.
Yeah. Go straight to edit. Go for it.
Yep. Yeah. It's just in, like, start getting
the one and keep public.
And then what we thinking? The
Let's comment comment out this rewrite block so
that the
Comment it out? That's a bit cautious.
Alex. That that's Alex all over. That's why
he's awesome on the team. He's super cautious
because, yeah, I was thinking, like, d d.
I'm just gonna press up d.
Exactly.
That's what d d and I do in
DevRel. Right? Yeah.
Brilliant.
Cool. You over that?
Yep.
And
now
Let's maybe restart the core DNS server. I
don't know if the configuration map will automatically
reload or if we should force a restart.
Yeah. What's the what's the best command for
that one? So if I do
TTL get
is it, like, in the name of this
cube system?
Just we just restart?
The pod probably. Can see I'll get pod.
Yep.
Alright. You just have ten minutes.
Yeah. So we've two pods there?
Yep.
Just delete?
Or Delete. Delete.
Yeah. Can yep.
CTL.
Delete.
What's usually take a while to okay. That
that was fast. Yeah.
That's pretty good. Did you want yeah. If
I change the final one there
to TBH4S4S.
Yep.
And then we probably wanna do the same
thing with our application.
If there are connections established already to the
wrong Postgres
instance.
Like it. Forced to reconnections. Good point.
Yeah.
And see if could restart with that Rust
app. Right? So
should we try
calling local host?
Different error. Failed to connect to database. It's
a different
So one down.
What's the next one?
So it's a hard coded value in the
app reaching out to that. There was a
very pertinent comment
from the
chat.
It was the endpoints, I believe, for this.
That's right.
There we go. It was the
Narla Patel there.
The Postgres service has no endpoints on the
default namespace. Oh, interesting.
Well, thank you So probably label selectors or
something of the sort.
Yes. That's the best way to figure that
one out.
Get endpoint
but no.
Yeah. We can do some analysis or look
directly at the the labels that are applied
to the Postgres deployment and compare the label
selectors in the Postgres service.
Or should we describe
the service
for Postgres?
Mhmm.
Q o. It's
just Postgres.
Oh,
No endpoints.
Good catch, Narla.
Nothing. None none. Right? On the labels on
the endpoints.
Oh, I'm sorry. There is actually on the
label selectors,
app equal Postgres.
Sorry. Yeah.
Alex, what was that?
There yeah. I was just pointing to the
app equals
pro equals Postgres.
So Oh, I gotcha. On the selector. Sorry.
Yeah. Yep.
So you're gonna wanna check that pod and
see if the labels match up.
Mhmm.
Yeah. On the Postgres pod.
Label's none.
Alright.
You wanna see that one at the top?
So do have Kubel edit?
The old favorite. Go for more time.
Exactly. One more time.
There is I can just find it. How
much of the pod spec is immutable, though?
Oh.
I don't remember if labels are or not.
Yeah. So we probably should modify the statefuls,
sir?
Deployment for the cluster one. Yeah. The deployment.
K. Keep CTL,
edit
the cluster service, did you say? Deployment.
The deployment.
The final label. Clustered one, but the Postgres
one.
Yes. Sorry.
It's a stable set for STS.
Yeah.
Oops. Press q l.
There we go. We'll get it.
Awesome. We're in.
Yeah. I wrote these manifests. I don't even
remember.
It's fine. There we go. At postgres.
Oh, is there a mutating
webhook or something?
That's
changing that.
Could be. Yep. More for Luke.
Yep.
Got five minutes or just under five minutes.
I
think the Fairwinds team might have a specific
on this one. What is it? Get mutating
webhooks? I can never really Mutating webhook configuration.
Nice long one there for you. That's a
long one.
No recesses found.
Any
thoughts?
I would encourage you to use the hints
given how little Yeah. Time there is. It
doesn't hurt to use the hints and and
get
maybe catch one more time.
Ejecting HTML is so easy when you control
the database. That was your suspicion, David. Right?
Yeah. I'm gonna have to sanitize my inputs.
Lesson learned.
We do it like another
we sort of need that. I've never seen
that SQL injection go the other way. On
the database side. Yeah.
Nice. Should we do the other?
Three.
DNS.
That's it. Right? DNS. There's
no way to that. Right? DNS.
Yeah. We're good for
you know, you can just name a naked
pod the same as what a control expects?
I did not.
Right. Did you
Ah, okay.
So
let's just delete this pod.
Yeah. And let the country actually
It's the Postgres pod. Postgres
Yeah. Quick. Nick it with fire. You've got
you've got it's three minutes.
New CTL.
Delete
pod. What was the
Postgres,
yeah,
cool URL dash o one.
PostgresQL,
o one?
I should And maybe Postgres. I don't know.
Yeah. Let's just if you get supports. Yeah.
Yeah. Oh, just deal. O.
Yep.
Yep. Lost my turn up. I don't know.
Interesting.
Should we just do a
Yeah. Yeah. Go for it.
It failed. Well, it may not be running
yet, to be fair.
Yeah. So this is Oh, it's gone.
That's
intriguing. Right? It's just default set replicas
set to zero?
Is the deployment
set?
The stateful set. The stateful set.
In
in the other namespace or No. In this
one.
So what's the what's the command to run?
I mean, I would just edit the stateful
set and then search for replicas and see.
So kubectl
edit.
S t s. Yeah.
Post SQL.
There we go. Touch four. Zero replicas.
Ah, yes. I see it.
That's alright. That's That's alright. Click here. Yeah.
One minute. You're
kinda close. Yes.
We do we do have me too. Right?
But kinda like a like.
Oh, that's that's b one?
Your
bag, your bag is not a success. Yeah.
Yeah. It looks like it worked. It worked.
But we didn't is it got b two,
though? Let me show us that. Yeah.
Yeah. And where we changed the v two?
Did we reverse back to v one?
Not sure.
Oh, Pairwinds insights can help you with resource
risk in limits.
I
I think it is. I think
it's just a video.
I think I remember what resource.
There you go. No. Oh, it is. Yeah.
It's just my it's just my
my browser being a little bit weird, but
you got the video.
It was all. Awesome. Great work there. Well
done. On the nick of time. Yay.
Awesome team. Right on time. Late than never
used slap. Alright.
Well, thanks for that. You said great. You
just got it fixed. You had like ten
seconds left. So you know loads of time
for debug in there.
I'm gonna ask you kindly say thank you,
but I ask you all to pop off
and we'll get the fair win team and
they'll see what you've done to your cluster.
So thank you again. Well done. Thanks, David.
Thanks, David.
Alright. I'll just pop over here until we
get the Fairmans team over.
Get my cluster back up.
Ambassador
Labs.
Alright. Cool. They're all
getting here now.
We've got Brian,
Andy's back.
Hello.
How's it going?
Oh, and Robert.
There you go. Oh, we got a fourth.
And
Robert.
Oh,
someone is still watching. I would encourage you
to close your YouTube tab.
Oh, someone is still watching. I would encourage
you to close your YouTube tab.
Oh, some of those were still watching. Oh,
two of you are still watching. Okay. I'm
gonna mute all of
the fear of wins team until someone walks
out where that tab is. You got it?
Cool. Alright. We're back.
Sneaky work there. Well done.
Before
we talk about that, why don't we do
a little bit of round of introductions? We'll
just start from the top right with you,
Brian, go around clockwise. Please feel free to
say hello and share a little bit about
yourself.
Sure. Hey. I'm Brian, customer
reliability engineer here at Fairwinds.
I joined two months ago, but
I actually worked here for several years previously.
And really excited to be back and and
part of this team here.
Alright.
Sam?
Hi. Thanks.
Samantha McAuley here. I've been with Fairwinds for
a few months. Also a,
SRE with,
Brian. And
just
happy to be aboard and and having fun
here. Thanks.
Awesome. Thank you.
Robert?
I'm, Robert Brennan. I'm a
I, I'm a software developer.
I lead the team building Fairwinds Insights, which
are our commercial platform for doing, Kubernetes governance.
And, Andy, there you go.
Hey, y'all. I'm Andy, director of r and
d and technology here.
I've, been doing Kubernetes for
so many years now, and it's just super
fun to be back here. This is a
total blast. So thanks for having us.
Yeah. Welcome back.
Doing a reverse SQL injection into my application
was particularly sticky because in my head, I
was trying to fix the wrong thing, I
think for a while in there,
trying to work out how you potentially replace
the image.
I like that. That was very
sneaky.
All right. I think it's only fair now
to hand a cluster over to you. So,
I'm gonna pop my screen share back up
and I will open a connection
on Farewell. Oh, no, not Farewells. Ambassador
Labs control plane
one. Please remember to use activity, active sessions
and join rather than creating your own session,
just so that we're all typing into the
same window. And if you could all give
me a echo hello, that would be awesome.
And I will get one more extra picture
of on the screen because we're missing one.
Yeah. Just do this all ad hoc. I
don't need me. I'm good.
All right. We've got a few hellos there.
So
feel free to set up your KubeConfig and
aliases,
check for a control plane and best of
luck team.
But who have we got driving today?
Oh, yeah. That would be me.
So
yeah. Feel the curse everyone feels when you
screen share screen.
Everything suddenly goes to nowhere. So where is
this one, Andy? It was in Etsy.
Etsy Kubernetes
admin dot com.
There we go.
And, Brian, I understand. I drove last time,
and I still don't remember all the details
of what happened because it was just, like,
total blur.
Uh-oh.
You have no control play. Let's
take a look at what's in that cube
config. It looks like Yeah. It's missing some
information.
Client keys data.
Is that the right key? Is it supposed
to be client key data?
Client key must be specified.
Client key data.
Yeah. There's client key data.
And it says client keys data. Is that
supposed to be plural?
I don't think so. I think Not
based on this error.
Errors of the very wary, I think.
Yeah. I'm very wary of typos after last
time because we spent, what,
fifteen minutes staring at that YAML trying to
find a typo last time.
Alright. So I'm just gonna ditch that guy
that one there.
Oops.
You
can specify aliases.
That's right. Ex what is that? Export. I'll
do that later.
Looks like we're still not getting it.
Yeah. It's asking for client key data still.
Yeah. Thought we
are we in the right config?
Let me get out of there.
It's there.
Where is client key data?
It's in the right place?
Is it, yeah, is it indented properly?
So can't we just use
QADM to give us a new config
so we don't have to try and figure
out all the things that might be wrong?
Sure.
Remember the command for that?
Oh, no.
I think it's let's see.
I think it's just kubeadm kubeadm config.
Yep.
Kubeadm
kubeadm
config.
Let's see. Would it be user?
Have you used the Internet as a generator
config?
Or is the user command necessary?
No. I gotta have something there.
You can try Kubernetes dash admin.
But I think without the user.
Oh, without user. No. No. Wipe user. I
think that is the user. Yeah.
Gotcha.
It might want a flag. Oh, I got
the flag. The flag. Again, screen sharing. Apologies.
I know. It's user and then dash dash
help. It must want maybe dash dot. I
don't know if it wants a flag for
the Kubernetes admin or not. Oh, right. Right.
Right. Right. Right.
I
don't know. I've never used this this command
before.
Oh, what I'm let's see. I'm looking at
this.
No. I see.
Q config user dash dash client dash name
That's it. Equals
dash admin.
That's But we need the q a d
m
config file for this cluster. So we need
dash dash config,
and I don't know where that is.
K.
But you can try it without the last
flag and see what it does.
K.
Config not set. Alright.
Alright. Let's see.
There is no Kubernetes and config left on
the machines after the provisioning step, I'm afraid.
Okay. Alright.
Then let's let's
look at
because
Why yeah. Why is it still complaining about
the the key
key not being there?
Good question.
Let's take a look at that thing again,
shall we?
Yeah. Yeah.
The admin.com
file?
Two.
With which kubectl.
Okay.
And
let's check for aliases too.
Okay.
That's sneaky. Because, like
Yeah. That would be sneaky. You could just
type alias. Yeah. That will list them all.
Just type alias. Yeah.
Up to date. I don't see anything there.
Someone suggested looking for a backup of something.
Wonder if it's hidden somewhere.
I don't know. Let's go back to what
what we were looking at the queue. The
admin conference. Right? It's not
red hair and YouTube part of it.
So you have client key data, client certificate
data.
Oh, wait. No. That's
cluster. Contacts.
User your Kubernetes admin. That matches the name.
That oh, check your contacts.
That's right. Yeah. Kubectl yeah. The name of
the context.
Is that correct? Do a kubectl config get
context.
Oops.
It does look okay in the file.
So we specify for Kubernetes admin.
To use the client. Why
is it doing that when you say kubectl
config,
though? That says to me that something's been,
yeah,
messed with here
with the kubectl
binary itself.
Wow.
Cat
user bin kubectl.
Uh-oh.
Oh, alright.
I mean, I if I was gonna be
really mean, I would replace it with a
bad script. Can you type reset to clean
that up?
I I did the same thing, and it
worked okay.
My my apologies.
How do we get out of this one?
Guess I could've used file instead. That would've
been Yeah.
Yeah.
I think I'll just close this terminal.
Alright. So I
let's close this. The session will disappear.
Okay. We have a
I missed it.
There you go.
Okay. Connect.
Oh, I can't spell control plan. Apologies.
Okay. We have a new session. Please join
that.
The one that says
could just close the one you're in just
now. Just jump into the one that's been
open for a few seconds and reconfigure
your config and hope for the best.
And
for the record, that is two people that
have captured a binary file in the last
two episodes. So
Do you want me to use file on
that, Andy?
No. I mean, we know it's a binary
now.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I guess it could
be the wrong binary, but we would I
was gonna say maybe. Download
a new maybe?
Yeah. We could get a new just grab
a new one just in case.
Let's see.
It helps if you use grab. Me in
the other room. Sorry. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Grab.
It's been there for a while.
Okay. Yeah.
Hello.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah. There must be hints. Yeah.
Was gonna say, are there other hints?
It's functionally similar to Carta.
So a typo? Don't count don't count them
all. There's
That's what Carta did.
There's an element of the eighties soft sell
song here.
Brian, you're our music expert.
Tainted Love.
So there's tape somewhere. But
That sounds like that sounds like a typo
that we're missing maybe. So let's maybe take
a look at that admin conf again.
Okay.
I got
Cluster, I mean, right, is there
is there more going on, like, above here
that I can't see? Here we go.
Clusters
cluster
name, Kubernetes,
context cluster user, Kubernetes admin.
Contact's name is Kubernetes admin at Kubernetes.
Current context matches that.
Client's
I wish you all the spaces and tabs.
I have curiosity.
Say that again?
Is YAML fine with spaces and tabs? I'm
guessing.
You know, like Oh. Like What what have
we got before the client key data about,
could it could it be a tab character
or something?
Could be, but I don't think the actual
cares. Does it?
It could if it's
oh, no. Yeah. I think you'd get a
different error message.
But it's weird that it's saying there's no
client key data.
That is weird. Like,
if if can you if can you edit
the file with with them just to, like,
see if they're letting any hints?
It's that little add add add at the
bottom.
That's just them.
Oops.
Is
that the right number of spaces
in front of client key data? I can't
actually tell from here.
Yeah. It looks like it. Looks like four
spaces. Can
you
Yeah. Go down there. Let's see. One, two,
three, four.
Yep.
That's four.
I'm looking
at a cube config for a kind cluster
locally.
Yeah.
So
suggested our client certificate data and client key
data swapped.
They
could
be I'm not sure how we would let's
see. Just, like, chain change the keys
back and forth? Like, change the lines to
try it. Data.
Okay. Do wanna
oops.
Like that?
Yeah.
I don't think you ever
I saved that. Did you export the
you export the Kube config again?
Probably
No. Copy of this file.
Then why is it still doing this thing?
Oh, you're right.
Export econfig
equals
Etsy.
How
is it still giving us the same error
no matter what we do? I think This
is not right. I
think need a new There's alternative ways to
set the cube config. What about the flag
on the cube control?
Yeah.
I I would try that. We checked.
The dash dash cube config equals
Yeah.
And let's just rule out some environment
trickery.
And then the last thing I'll suggest is
there are other cube configs in that directory
for the other controller managers, etcetera, that may
be able Yeah.
That would be
yeah.
It's true. We could try any one of
those.
I mean, if we wanna grab a new
kubectl binary, I have the command here. You
could also do apt get install dash dash
reinstall
kubectl if
you wanna refresh it.
It's like that one?
Yeah. I don't know if it'll more of
it reinstalled flag beam before install, but give
it a shot.
K. I'll put that at the end.
Or
Yeah. Take it there.
K.
Same error.
Alright. So it doesn't Should we try one
of those other KubeConfigs?
Or
What does k version show just to make
sure we're using one dot 23 dot four?
It's 23 dot three.
But something's a weird, but it should be
Oh, k k version dash dash
Is it that's just client only or that's
just client? Client
on
wow. It's not liking any of that.
It's not the real c t l binary.
There's no way.
Yeah. Something's weird here.
Beautiful. Just here.
Can I download that binary to Loco?
Oh, you could always just instead of using
alias and keep control, like, fully,
like, do slash then keep control and then
you're guaranteed.
Or you could do that. Try the one.
Try try
the one in that slash. Although that has
been really fast.
Try that slash q back tool. You need
to plus exit.
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Different. We
swapped the Yes. We we did that. Right?
The key the key and the certificate. Yeah.
We need go swap those back or use
a different KubeCon thing. Alright. Should I move
this file over to user
Yeah. Join? I don't think it's gonna make
a difference. I think what's in user Ben
is correct. I think you'll find there's something
in the bash profile possibly that is being
very sneaky here. But if you fully qualify,
could control all the time as slash user
slash bed slash control, you should be okay.
You can you can tell us to this
current one. Yeah. Maybe something in bash or
c or dot profile. It could be anywhere,
to be honest. Oh.
Mean, we've we've gotten around it. We don't
have to know what it is. Yeah. Exactly.
Gone out of this cluster and move on.
There you go.
It's the function. There it is. Yeah. Okay.
Oh. Oh, man.
That's
oh, man. That's so good. That is exactly
what we did to Carta, isn't it? With
a function instead of an alias so that
they wouldn't be able to find it. That's
so good.
You need to do that. Sorry. Yeah. You're
on it.
Okay.
That doesn't am I on it?
Yeah. The source I thought would have like,
you could do unset cube control.
Yeah. That would be good.
Okay. There we go. There we go. Okay.
Back to
wow. Man.
We're
We're out. Alright. So just swap these over.
Yeah.
Think y'all counted on our memories being better
than they are.
Alright. Back to our regularly scheduled program.
Alright. Let's see what we got for pods
and deployments and such in this name space.
I love that they watched that episode. They
used that trick against you.
Oh, so good.
Apparently, I should've done the same.
Got one that's pending.
Alright.
Alright. Well, based on hint number two Oh,
yeah. You no taints. Right?
Tainted love.
I bet we're gonna see something around tolerations
or taints.
Yeah. So
There's nothing embarrassing about knowing that soft sales
can take a good lump. I'm not I'm
just gonna throw that out. No. It's a
wonderful thing.
Let's see.
There we go.
What do you see?
I see a taint here. Right? If you
can use the last pager, it just means
the audience can follow along as well. Oh,
sorry. Okay.
Are you all bits are you all able
to see that taint? Yep. Yeah. It's there's
a no no schedule taint.
Oh, alright. Yep.
Should I just delete that off those nodes?
Mhmm.
Yes.
K. Is that through edit, or is there
another way to do that? There is a
nice sweep, but nobody remembers it. I would
edit.
I'm just speaking for a second. I'm just
saying that. It's like, I I I know
how to create one, but I don't remember
how to remove one intentionally. It's it's the
same, but you put a dash on the
end of the tenth.
That's it. That's it. Definitely not gonna remember
that.
Yeah.
I'm still relying on keep control edit these
days. It's unbelievable.
Okay. And then worker two.
Alright. That's good news. Running.
Let's edit the deployment to v two and
see what happens. I suppose we should look
and see if the app's even running on
v one. But
Yeah. Let's do that first.
Was that a curl command? Or Local host
30,000.
That's not fun. Yeah. That's not working.
Import 30,000.
Check the endpoints.
How much is that right?
Yeah.
Yep. That's the right pod
or that's the right
Is it the right port?
The port is correct. Yes.
Okay. K.
Cluster runs on eighty eighty.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna assume Daniel with his love for
the JVM has stuck it on a machine,
and now all networking is broke because the
JVM is stuck in all the
Should we look at hint three?
What did what did the curl sound there?
I don't think you need hint three.
In the return. Alright. But what's the symptom
here? Right? You're you're trying to curl a
service. It doesn't work. So
Right.
Let's check for network policies.
Yeah. Good shit.
Do a
default log.
What can we do that as as the
animal? Twenty three hours old. I don't think
that exists normally.
I mean, the name would it looks legit.
Right?
The name looks legit, but I I don't
don't think you need that.
Let's see.
Policy rights egress.
No rule. Pod selector is nothing, though. But
that
Doesn't that select all pods, though, on a
network policy?
Yeah. It seems like that. I'll just delete
it.
Yep. The network policy. Yeah. Nothing good ever
came from leaving something lighter. I'd like that.
K. Let's try our curl again.
Hey.
Yep. That's v one. Did we edit the
deployment already? I can't remember.
Not yet.
Like that one?
Yep.
Check curl.
The new one wasn't ready yet. I'm not
sure.
Do we do we get get network policies
again?
Wow. Came back.
Oh.
Okay. That's what
Is it
It would it would have a control plane
name if it was a static manifest. We
learned that while trying to break the other
cluster.
Let's do a get pos dash capital a
and see what else is running. It's probably
something recreating
it maybe.
You're right. Unless it is a a static
pod or well, no. Let's Kube VIP. I
don't that doesn't look familiar. That's a bare
metal BGP broadcaster and load sponsor. You don't
need to worry about that. That's supposed to
be there. I mean, as to it as
a KubeFit. I don't I I right now,
I don't know. But Yeah. Yeah.
I can't remember if there was a Cilium
operator
or not.
There is that look I mean, besides the
twenty four hours ago restart on it, it
looks okay. It passes the eyeball test.
Controller managers.
Cube scheduler ambassador labs control Plane 1. That's
correct. I just remembered that the cluster is
called ambassador labs, not heroins because I was
Two core DNS pods,
cluster pod.
I mean, does the sneaky thing have to
be a container?
No. It could be a process system as
well. Yeah. Yeah.
Maybe edit
the cron job file?
It could be a cron job.
Yeah. Do it. Can repeat it again? Cron
jobs. Oh.
I mean,
like a Oh, on the system. On the
system. The system crontab. It could be a
system crontab. Yeah. Yeah. We spent so much
time in Kubernetes. We forgot how Linux works.
Yeah. Crontab dash e, you think?
Yeah.
Oh, there it is. Nice.
Nice.
Oh, and it's gonna automatically set that too.
Right?
Yeah. Both of those. Yeah. Yeah.
So just delete those? Yeah. Make those go
away.
And then Okay. Have to reload that. Right?
Edit the deployment. Right? Yeah.
Use just the cron tab anymore.
Okay. We don't have to be
My screen is not letting me see everything
very nicely. Okay. There we go.
And then
Okay.
curl.
Still says we want
Oh, he's dancing now. That may be my
browser cache, which is always really bad for
this. So
is it v one or v
two, is it? One in the title.
Oh, that could be a bug too, to
be honest.
Yeah. Should we start loading it up in
the background?
How do we know?
I I I think it fixed it. I
mean, if you describe the pod and it
says v two and my browser says v
two, I'm happy that it's v two.
Dude, dude, just grab it, Will you? Please.
Maybe
I'll update the title for the next episode.
I kept wondering about that when I was
testing it. I was like, it still says
v two in the title. I just assumed
it was browser cache. Alright.
Yeah. That says v two. Successfully build. I
think you have fixed that cluster, and you
had a whole nine minutes left to spare.
There you go.
That was fun. Awesome.
That was very
nice work. Ambassador folks. That was cool. That
was great. Yeah. Some dark arts we don't
usually deal with. I mean, dropping down to
content on the Linux host was pretty amusing.
Okay.
Alright.
Well well done. You smashed that. Like I
said, nine minutes left. That's that's rare on
custard. So well done.
Good team effort there.
So thank you for for joining me. And
I'm sure we'll have you back for a
third time in the future.
Awesome. Thanks for having us. Alright.
Thank you all.
Alright. That was two great clusters, two great
teams, everything fixed. I mean, that's a pretty
good episode of
Clustered. I'm really happy with that. And it
was fun. I was laughing all the way
through that. So thank you for joining us
and watching all your comments and the chat.
I just want to say thank you again
to Teleport. You've seen us use this tool
on this episode and every other episode. It's
just an amazing tool that I really genuinely
believe everybody should have installed on all of
their environments.
So you can support the show by checking
out rockode.liveteleport.
And also thank you to Equinix Metal for
providing all the bare metal machines that we
use for this. We will be back
tomorrow.
We had to reschedule last week's episode because
everyone had more important things to be doing,
but we will have another episode tomorrow
where we will be joined by Adrien and
William from the Discord community. So we will
see you all then. Have a wonderful day
everyone, and I will see you all soon.
Thank you very much.